he's not gonna do
this go push i'm not doing that
his body will move he pushes me
my body moves my whole body do you see
that
i push him no
you push me i move my butt he's moving
me move me
and i let him move me then i push
don't let your arm disengage from your
body
he pushes i push
he put it it's loose there
keep it connected here tight in there
there you go oh
so i feel his center and he'll feel mine
whoa he keeps the ass
that's it oh
i move him he moves me
i keep my center
i move him go that's not
centered you see that i keep my arm
in relationship with my body
okay try push shift your weight
no not your arm your arm
keep your arm long and you shift your
weight
yes there you go my turn
keep your arm long take your weight back
shift your weight back
don't lean back bend your back knee
that's
it keep your arm long long and now shift
your weight forward
good my turn shift your weight back
good and shift your weight forward come
on
good shift your weight back
shift your weight forward good
okay that's the next stroke
this time i'm going to be your kid
so i'm going to grab him and he's not
going to grab me
i'm going to shift his weight back
then he's going to shift his you're
leaning back through though
then he's gonna shift his weight this
arm is dead
i shift him back and he shifts forward
i'm gonna let my balance step
then i'll set up again shift and back
you're leaning backwards so
shift back means you bend your back leg
that's it
then you shift forward bend the front
leg
okay when i'm uk
i don't let my arm bend go
you see that i keep that same connection
that he has
extension i shift him back
and he goes forward
shift him back make your backhand alive
spread your fingers put it in the fight
spread your fingers then he shifts
forward
okay let's go lock it all in place good
and when you feel pressure here you move
here
you move this back okay
yes and now lock it all in place and now
you move forward
good and we do the same thing
yes good
and i'm doing it too azuki so i
lock everything in place and
i move in and then when i feel your
pressure
i let my center move
i don't go go let my arm move you see
that
i move my center forward you move yours
back
and i let you move my center go back
okay go thank you yourself for the uk
drill he pushes come on
come on and i'm connected
i'm going to be connected in a very
relaxed way
oh he pushes i should be able to
shake out that energy out of my body
so these are mistakes he goes
mistake he goes
mistake i'm fighting
pushes
mistake this spine broke
push
tension think of it like a bolt of
electricity
he goes and
let it shake out
shift load his back foot he goes
shake it out relax without breaking
connection
load his back foot he goes
okay you go thank you very much okay
jessie's job is to look like the teacher
so i load his back foot
then he goes you're gonna look like me
no
i'm gonna load your back foot and then
he goes
no i will load your back foot so right
now you're fighting me okay
shift your weight onto your back foot
now you're going to
project through me
we do the other side loads the back
foot then he goes
here was you
see the difference he's going to move my
whole body i'm going to feel that energy
through my whole
my body body's gonna move okay try good
load my back foot good
let your body go backwards load my back
foot
so rather than leaning backwards wait
i'll move you don't worry
lock your body lock your body lock your
body
lock your body your arms bend your arm's
not locked
your shoulders aren't locked lock your
body
no no if your shoulders are turning lock
it in place
lock it no look it's turning again it's
turning again there you go
make it tighter don't let your shoulder
turn don't let your shoulder turn
lock it there lock it
it's to turn again lock it push with
your shoulder
good and now let your body walk back
that's it here we go love my back foot
good and let your body walk back you're
leaning back
before you lean walk back push
don't lean back walk back without
unlocking your arm load my back foot
and let me walk back there you go
push now i'm going to load you and
you're going to want to get
like that keep your arm locked more load
my back foot
there you go load
good boy like that
load good
good i'm gonna do it harder so you got
to do it better here we go
change your feet change your feet go to
my back foot
oh get ready good
lock it lock it wait for me to push you
there you go lock your body
good
load good
load
good
load good okay
so we're gonna do the drill
from not him loading my foot okay
this is dead still i i don't feel your
your center
you feel mind push you see okay
well look at yours wants to turn and
stuff and this is shoulder tension and
jaw tension
so push on me look how i'm still talking
here still relaxing
okay i'm not going yeah
okay so that's how you have to be all
right so
i'm gonna now turn his arm you're gonna
keep your grip
so i'm gonna do that sword movement i
have the sword
and i'm gonna turn it
then do the other side turn
then the other side turn
okay you're disconnected do it
underneath
you go you see the dead ring
this is you cosmetically stepping over
and it's dead right this is you
i'm going to keep this connection i push
through my center
and he'll move me i don't disconnect
go do you see i keep the same
packed shoulder
i let him move me are you shifting your
weight
no it's the same as the sword movement
so here we go lock everything
okay go watch me again
who do you have to look like when you're
dishing
the teacher right okay so he goes this
is you
you disconnected you
i connect everything he goes and he
moves my whole body
i disconnect it does not move my body
i connect everything he goes oh
i want to organize my body so it's a
unified mass
there you go are you alive be alive
okay are you alive is it with your
center or your shoulder
see how my elbow's far from here
good
but you're dead right when you come in
right when you come in you see
you're going to grab like that yes alive
grab alive
okay let's go this connection this
organization of my body
so i start from out of range and i come
in and he goes
okay try it but you have a lot of things
you can do too
because you let the range close so his
arm went
lift then i can do a lot of things
when his arm is not lift then i kept a
deal with the grip
you're still doing shoulder and not
center connection
okay i have to deal with the grip
there you go just relax your shoulder
you should be able to rotate it just
relax
not just go back and forward
it's not able to rotate
this is me just sending the ground
energy to it it's not able to rotate
because you don't have it relaxed
okay
good it's not able every time
you've got to be able to do everything
got to be able to cut there too
okay
she's got to be able to rotate you got
to be able to rotate
there you go
there you go good
good okay
good
good connection all the way through
push disconnect
push there you go
so he goes disconnect
he goes disconnect here right
hey grab my head you see
i keep connected the whole way through
i grab connected lower your hand
okay
okay let's go
there you go good girl
good feel that good feel that
good excellent same thing
feel oops
there you go good okay let's go
okay leave that there you're gonna turn
your hand
that way step
take a bigger steps try it again
pulls your shoulder what's your arm
leave it no it's your shoulder turn your
body
when your leg goes oh you went too far
oh oh
oh
does everyone see her body turning okay
so
do this with your thumb to help your
shoulder
step when you do it step when you do it
you got to get lower touch the ground
there you go either side just like that
open your hand and your thumb's going to
turn you're going to step
and you're going to touch the ground
turn up
start with your thumb turn yes
other side live hand
oops keep your foot low to the ground
and start with your thumb turn
yes good okay
let's go like that
good sam
beautiful
good you see he's got that back slide
going
excellent good
good now except to the outside of his
body
this is the outside okay
let's go my whole body is going to move
boom together oh
the difference does that look powerful
no it looks like he has dust on him and
i'm trying to get the dust off his ghee
okay boom the same thing goes when
we throw i don't throw like this
my whole body moves
do you see that